hello everyone uh this is daniel
and today i'm gonna be recording
a long-awaited video that i've been
planning to make for a long time
and uh the background surrounding this
video
i is that over the course of the last
couple of months
um i've played hundreds of bullet games
that is one minute games against one
relatively unknown player magnus carlsen
uh on leachate.org
and um i think there's been a lot of
down time with corona so magnus has
come on to leech us and he's established
total domination over both the blitz and
bullet pools
and i've had the honor and privilege of
playing a couple very very long matches
against magnus and you know these
matches will last
well over 100 games and we'll go back
and forth of course magnus has a hefty
plus score
um in a later video i'll actually look
up what our score is
but i've also had the pleasure of uh
you know playing a couple of very very
interesting games against him
and displaying a couple of very
interesting combinations and today
i'd like to show you guys the finale of
one of our bullet games in which i
managed to play
what i think is perhaps my most
beautiful
sequence of moves that is a combination
um i've ever played in a bullet game
and you know definitely the nicest thing
that i managed to do against magnus
now the position in front of you
occurred in a game
in a match that we played on may 4th of
this year
uh i had the black pieces i go by
rebecca harris
and magnus who goes by dr nichterstein
as the white pieces and on the notation
panel you're welcome to
play through the game if you'd like to
see how this position was reached now
it's clear from the position that white
is going this way so white is
threatening to promote his pawn
and uh quick look at the position uh may
reveal that
it might be time for me to resign
because although i have two past pawns
of my own
uh they're not close to promotion and
they're they're being blockaded by
uh white's king for example if i give a
check
and then magnus goes king to b2 well
there's nothing i can do to stop this
spawn from promoting
and becoming a new queen for example i
just move my bishop he promotes
and the game is over now
the same goes for a move like b2 you
know he just promotes his queen and
once again there's no way i can push my
own pawns to promotion
and it was at this point with
approximately 10-15 seconds on the clock
that i discovered a very very
interesting idea
and the idea starts with a very
unassuming looking move king c3 now what
am i doing i'm
allowing him to promote his pawn um it
appears that i'm not really achieving
anything but i had cooked up
a devilish scheme now magnus you know
he also has whatever 10 15 seconds i i
don't remember the exact time stamp
immediately promotes to a queen and
at this point i would encourage you to
pause the video
um and try to relive the suspense put
yourself in my shoes give yourself a
couple minutes on the clock
try to come up with anything something
that i can do here and there is
something that i can do here
now the combination starts with the move
a2 check which is reasonable enough
but magnus had first seen this he plays
king to a1 no problem
it appears that black is at a complete
standstill now of course
he doesn't go the other way because i'd
simply promote to a queen and
this is checkmate but now
i i play the move b2 check again this is
not checkmate
magnus simply captures one of my one of
my past pawns
and again it seems that resignation may
be a viable option here
but the checking continues and i give
another check with my bishop bishop b3
check
and all of a sudden i think at this
point it dawned on magnus
that something was amiss now the king
has two retreat squares
the move king b1 is punished rather
mundanely i still think this is cool
because white isn't a whole queen to the
good
and yet this queen is is totally
immobile it's not participating in the
action
so i give this check now notice how the
bishop is controlling the promotion
square
i promote to a queen with check king to
a3 and queen a1 mate now
as a general rule of thumb for the more
advanced players among you
when you're calculating pawn races in
the end game
you know the player who promotes first
or the player who promotes with check
often times has a huge huge advantage so
you know this check this power of the
move
um gives you everything that that you
need so
to come back to the critical position
the king cannot return to p1 for that
reason
now from a distance when he was
promoting magnus had calculated this
line and he'd seen king a3
and this indeed is what happened in the
game so i'm just going to promote this
variation this position occurred
and if you had been calculating this
perhaps you thought that black and
promotes a queen
which would be a very reasonable move
but you have to realize that number one
white is up four pawns
number two if you notice this x-ray that
the knight is creating
queen is creating against black's king
that is why can uh do what's called a
discovery discovered check knight f3
check
and uh not again not only is white four
pawns up but he's also winning more
material for example if the king drops
back
well then white can simply pick off uh
black's
queen via fork and uh you know this is
essentially over the win is a matter of
just mopping things up here
but if you look at white's king very
very closely
it turns out that he actually has he i
guess it actually has no squares the
bishop is controlling these squares
the king is controlling these squares so
if only there was a way
to give a check to this king well this
would be checkmate and
already at this point drum roll please i
assume that you're seeing the move which
is not
queen but and this move is so rare that
it it literally
you know this program that i'm using
chess space i have to type the move in
it is b1 equals night checkmate
now let's unpack this for a second this
is called an under promotion
now when you promote you can make a
queen a bishop a knight or a rook
um and situations where you would need
to make something other than a queen
um that is something i want to probe in
future videos because it's just
fascinating
but in real games it's tremendously rare
um
and here i had the pleasure of
delivering this checkmate by promoting
to a knight
the king has no retreat scores as you
can see and the knight and the bishop
are all that is required working
in harmony in concert to deliver the
mate so very quickly to recap
this combination after the move h7
i go king c3 setting this all up
bringing the b2 square under control
magnus promotes
a2 check b2 check bishop b3 check
and now the final the coup d'etat b1
equals knight
checkmate now it turns out it turns out
that magnus actually could have won the
game after king c3
in this position magnus had a devilish
resource
that would have actually enabled him to
prevent this combination and win the
game
now i'll make this interesting for you
guys i won't reveal what it is until a
future video
and i'll be doing a lot of videos on
segments instructive and interesting
segments from my games with magnus
some that i won some that i lost and
i'll be revealing the solution to the
previous videos
um riddle in that video but for now i'd
encourage you to
to discuss in the comments section what
you think magnus can do in this position
to prevent uh this combination from
happening so
looking back it was a very very
satisfying moment um
i'm of course once again incredibly
honored and privileged to have the
chance to play magnus
let the record reflect that he usually
thrashes me um so this is
an anomaly but i will just flip to the
final position let me remove some of
these
declutter let me remove some of these
arrows just so you guys can see the made
in its pure form
b1 equals night checkmate so this was
probably my nicest combination against
the world champion
magnus carlson um and uh yeah so i hope
that you enjoyed this little tidbit i
once again will be doing a lot more
videos on
my interesting games against magnus some
will be more deeply analyzed
so i hope that you've enjoyed this
little exposition
and uh i'll be uploading more videos on
my lessons with charlie and on more
game segments and more instructional
videos all of that is coming
your way very soon so thank you very
much for watching and
hope to hear from you in the comments
section thank you